des bouteilles à perte de vue qu'elles
soient vertes blanches brunes plus de
25000 se trouve ainsi dans les murs de
ces trois maisons si particulière un
projet sans prétention qui aujourd'hui
continue de surprendre
on n'imaginait jamais lorsque mon père a
commencé sa constitution que 40 ans plus
tard ce serait encore ici il ya mantra
des gens qui viennent les visiter
tout a commencé en 1979 de retour d'un
voyage sur l'île de vancouver région
arsenault a donné l'idée à son père sans
imaginer un seul instant que ce dernier
se jettera corps et âme dans ses travaux
j'avais vu un site ce l'île de vancouver
qui était faite en bouteille j'ai
procédé j'ai apporté les cartes postales
et si lui tout ce qu'il nous a dit tout
d'un coup ils devaient serait pas me
faire seul os devrait être capable tel
ici pendant quatre ans entre 1980 et
edouard arsenault entrepris la
construction de la maison assis pignon
du phare et de la taverne le résultat
bluffant ne cesse d'attirer des
visiteurs toujours plus nombreux
ils étaient vingt mille l'an dernier un
record pour moi la messe en tout cas ça
représente la jeunesse
c'est un endroit qu'on vient de visiter
assez souvent et puis on a vu
l'évolution on a vu les jardins grand
air et c'est pour ça que je fus en fin
de semaine et à l'aube de son 40e
anniversaire le site traverse une
période difficile à cause de la cobi 19
les touristes sont moins nombreux
néanmoins pas question d'envisager une
fermeture
c'est dans le temps normaux on peut
avoir à 150 200 personnes par jour danse
à ce moment ici on a appris un appel 20
25 en personne au contraire sa
propriétaire voit les choses en grand
agrandissement installations de
sculptures d'artistes locaux création
d'un jardin ou encore d'un accès à la
mer sous traite qui savent est double la
grande affaire qu'en plus des sports ce
qui laisse aux prises un moyen pour elle
de donner rendez-vous en 2030 pour les
50 ans des maisons de bouteilles
ici j'ai dans le cachot radio-canada cap
ecms